somalia's president has agreed not to
extend his term amid domestic
and international pressure muhammad
abdullahi for major also promised to
hold early elections
he made the announcement after the prime
minister said he was against the
proposed two-year extension
while in the capital mogadishu many are
fleeing as unrest grows against the
government
residents fear more violence as armed
opposition fighters take up positions
around the city
the federal government of somalia has
always believed and still sees
dialogue compromise negotiation and the
return to the discussion table is the
only viable options
finally i urge all security agencies to
maintain the stability of the capital
and the safety of innocent civilians
avoiding any actions that may lead to
insecurity
i also urge the somali people to support
the armed forces in this regard
let's now bring in abdi samatar who's a
professor in the department of geography
environment and society at the
university of minnesota he's joining us
from minneapolis thanks for speaking to
us so
uh by making this announcement uh
is this likely to appease his opponents
pleasure to be with you dorian i don't
think so
because the president's attempt to
extend his
mandate by two years is both
unconstitutional according to the somali
constitution
and it was also illegal because the
opera house of parliament which should
have voted
on it did not do so so that's the first
thing
secondly he lost nearly all of the
international support
that somalia had because of this act and
finally his decision
to retreat of on this front doesn't
change
the political conflict between him and
the opposition
where they were unable to agree as to
who was going to manage the electoral
process
the president wants to run that process
although he is a candidate
the opposition disagrees with that and
that statement
stays in place right so what happens
next
given the degree of distrust among
somalia's politicians can a way forward
be agreed on
when i was in this show over the past
three months
i recommended to the united nations
special representative
that there needs to be an arbitra or a
negotiator between the different groups
an adjudicator who will tell who is
wrong and who is right depending on the
terms
of earlier agreements the un has failed
to do that
and so unless the african union or
somebody else can act as that mediator
i don't think they will come together to
be able to agree
on a path forward that will save the
people of madison and the rest of the
country from the crisis
how likely is it that a group such as
the african union will
will step in and presumably the
international community the au and the
eu and the un must be pleased with this
decision that the president is not
extending his term
i think they will be full-hearted to be
able to be pleased with themselves about
this
what is really necessary to get this
process forward
is to get a neutral electoral process
where all the candidates have a
reasonably fair chance
and that all actors who are legible can
participate in that process
the only volume forward in that regard
is to enforce
that to force the president to become a
neutral actor and hand
over the management of the election to
somebody else maybe the prime minister
maybe
a neutral body of civic leaders in the
country that's the only way out
but if the international community
thinks that what he has done today
on backpedaling on that unconstitutional
act is going to do the job
i think they are putting their head in
the sand one final question for you sir
how does the instability in somalia play
into the
hands of armed groups like al-shabab as
you know
who's been trying to topple the
government for many years
well the president's illegal act has
created a
power cake such that it has weakened
security systems in the country which
means that it has allowed al-shabab to
further penetrate both the capital and
the rest of the country
so that illegal act invited al-shabab to
sort of
restore their authority in many parts of
the country where they were losing in
the in the past
okay abdi samatar thank you so much for
joining us from minneapolis
good pleasure